the movie begins at the funeral of a
teenage boy named Darren Shan everyone
is devastated at his loss but shockingly
it turns out that he is very much alive
in fact he is seen inside the coffin
playing video games the scene then cuts
to the past and Darren explains how good
his life was going he was popular in
school had cool friends and good grades
which made his parents proud of him the
only negative part about his life was
his childhood best friend Steve one day
at school Steve convinces Darren to Bonk
their history class the two then head to
the rooftop where Steve destroys several
light bulbs by throwing stones at them
he then challenges his friend to do the
same but right then their history
teacher overhears the commotion coming
from the roof as a result the boys are
caught and their respective parents are
informed Darren comes off the worst of
it as his parents had always believed
him to be an ideal student they scold
him ruthlessly and also ground him for
two whole months furthermore they forbid
him from staying friends with Steve
citing that he is a bad influence it's
true Steve's a douche the next day while
walking to school Darren informs Steve
that his parents want him to break off
their friendship upon hearing this the
latter is disheartened and he accuses
Darren of never standing up for himself
as they quarrel a limousine passes by
and a man inside throws out a flyer
which lands in front of them it turns
out to be an invitation to a circus
event called a freak Show the flyer
claims that it is held once every 500
years the boys recall their teacher
giving them a warning against attending
the show because of its illegal nature
but they nevertheless decide to go to
the circus later that night Darren and
Steve sneak out of their homes and head
to the circus on their bicycles it's
revealed that the boys have peculiar
interests Darren is a big fan of spiders
while Steve is obsessed with vampires at
the venue they buy a ticket from a dwarf
human-like creature hiding behind a
curtain however when Steve hands it the
cash the creature bites his hand and
runs away
the boys shrug off the strange incident
one walk inside the theater it's
revealed that the show has attracted
people from diverse age groups mostly
adults and old people soon the show
commences and the host Mr tall gets on
stage he thanks the audience for coming
before presenting several strange freaks
before them at first a wolf man appears
and his presence scares everyone Mr tall
directs him towards a woman in the
audience and to everyone's horror The
Wolf Man tears off her hands but before
anyone can react the woman's hand
regenerates and she walks towards the
stage as if nothing has happened Mr tall
then introduces her as Coral limbs
another member of the freak show next up
is Alexander ribs a man with no apparent
ribs girtha teeth is the third member
and she can surprisingly break anything
with her strong teeth rhombus two
bellies her partner can eat anything due
to his two bellies he even swallows a
tricycle hole and spits it out in one
piece then a Beautiful Freak named
madame truska calls Darren on stage and
asks him to be her assistant however
when she touches his face she senses
something forbidden inside of him and
backs away as the performance continues
Madame truska Wows The Audience by
growing facial hair in an instant but
after her act she unexpectedly calls for
the show to be packed up despite her
request the next ACT larten cresply
takes the stage with his spider partner
OCTA he impresses the crowd with a dance
performance while playing an instrument
Steve recognizes larton from a book
about vampires and Whispers to Darren
that he is actually a vampire named
their Hosten just then the show is
interrupted by police and townspeople
including the boy's history teacher
while the adults argue Darren sneaks
backstage and steals OCTA fascinated by
its colorful appearance but as he
attempts to leave he is forced to hide
when someone enters the room to his
surprise larten appears with an old man
discussing the threat posed by a group
of hybrid vampires known as the
vampanese I hope you're all writing this
down because I have no idea what the
hell is going on suddenly Steve barges
in and begs them to turn him into a
vampire he says that he hates his life
because he has no one it turns out that
Steve's father went missing long ago
while his mother is a drunkard after a
lot of convincing lartin finally gives
in and decides to taste his blood
however the moment he puts it into his
mouth he realizes that Steve is a bad
person so he refuses to turn the boy
into a vampire prompting him to storm
off in Anger after a while larten
finally realizes that his spider has
gone missing but before he can check the
door Darren freaks out and runs away he
then reaches the road where he is picked
up by the same car from earlier inside
to men Merlot and Mr tiny start
interrogating him however it is soon
revealed that they picked up the wrong
boy they were actually looking for his
friend Steve so they dropped Aaron off
at his house but not before informing
him that they will be in touch the
following day Darren takes OCTA to
school in his bag hoping to keep her
safe however before the class even
starts Steve spots them he starts
playing with the spider and accidentally
drops her on the floor allowing her to
escape however instead of trying to
catch the spider Steve chases her with
an intent to kill causing a lot of
commotion in the halls of the school
many students run away in fear while
some even get injured having had enough
octave finally decides to act so she
bites Steve on his cheek before escaping
through the window as a result the
latter falls to the ground and gets
knocked unconscious because of the Venom
in the next scene Darren rushes back to
the circus and pleads with larten to
save his friend's life worried about the
repercussions of a human finding out
about their existence larten initially
refuses to help however he eventually
agrees to provide the antidote on one
condition that Darren becomes his
assistant vampire this means that he
will have to leave his family friends
and his entire social life Darren will
also have to give up going to school in
short he will have to die despite the
dire cushions Darren who is desperate to
save his friend agrees to the conditions
and receives larten's vampire blood
after this they race to the hospital to
save Steve's life lartin immediately
administers him with the antidote which
fortunately works and Steve starts to
recover the movie then cuts to a few
days later where Darren begins to feel
his body reacting to larten's vampire
blood he starts craving raw meat one day
he also gets a very tempting urge to
kill and suck his sister's blood however
he ultimately refrains himself from his
bloodlust and runs back to his room
there he finds a lardon sitting in the
corner reading his books lurt and warns
Darren that he needs to leave his home
as he is a threat to himself and his
family Darren doesn't want to do so but
after coming really close to harming his
own sister he decides to leave however
he also doesn't want his parents to keep
worrying about him forever so he decides
to fake his death later that night on
the rooftop of the house lartin assists
Darren in the act by breaking his neck
this will make everyone believed that he
accidentally fell to his demise the
movie then cuts to the present at
Darren's funeral all his friends
teachers and family pay their respects
while Darren is Alive and Well inside
the coffin playing games on his phone
the same night larten digs up the grave
and gets Darren out of the coffin but
before they can leave Merlot arrives out
of nowhere and ambushes them fortunately
larten fights him off and manages to
subdue him temporarily following the
close call he takes Darren to the freak
Show campgrounds where they meet a girl
named Rebecca meanwhile Steve is grief
stricken by his friend's death as a
result he distances himself from society
and becomes a maniac when the pain
becomes unbearable one day he
contemplates ending at all but just as
he is about to commit the unthinkable Mr
tiny arrives there and stops him he
mentions that he's aware of Steve's
unfortunate life and his obsession with
all things vampire he then offers him a
chance to become a vampanese it turns
out tiny and Merlot are vampanese and
they are A different race vampires who
unlike larten and the others murder
humans to feed on their blood it's also
revealed that vampanese and the normal
vampires are Arch enemies and they don't
see eye to eye as Steve hears everything
in disbelief Mr tiny discloses something
even more shocking he says that Darren
is alive and happy in the other world
something which Steve had always dreamed
of and aspired to the Revelation makes
the latter angry so without a second
thought he accepts the offer meanwhile
Darren slowly gets comfortable in the
freak Campground with the other freaks
he starts to train himself and helps
others in their duties one day Darren
goes through the pictures of his old
life and decides to give Steve a call
but before he can do so larten arrives
there snatches the phone from Darren and
breaks it that night Mr tiny visits the
freak Camp to talk with lartin and Mr
tall about Darren it turns out the boy
has special innate Powers so Mr tiny
asks him to hand them over despite being
enemies a diplomatic Mr tall politely
tells him that he will think of about it
afterwards larten instructs Darren not
to leave the camp as it is not safe for
him anymore he then begins to train
Darren so that he can handle himself if
he is ever in trouble at first the boy
fails to lay a single hand on larten but
as his training progresses his skills
and strength develop on the other hand
Merlot turns Steve into a vampanese
which gives him unreal Powers the boy
also becomes more evil and his first
victim turns out to be none other than
his history teacher you gave me an F F
is for fangs meanwhile as Darren begins
to feel hungry he starts craving for
fresh blood to remedy this larten takes
him to a nearby farm and sedates a man
he says that vampires never kill people
they just borrow their blood however
despite his hunger Darren cannot bring
himself to do it so they return back to
the camp shortly after the freak's
peaceful Campground is suddenly invaded
by a group of Ruthless vampanese chaos
ensues as the two sides engage in a
brutal fight light resulting in a lot of
Bloodshed it becomes clear that the
vampanese are searching for Darren and
soon enough they find him hiding inside
a costume room with Rebecca the
vampanese attacked Darren and a fierce
brawl breaks out but fortunately thanks
to the timely arrival of larton Mr tall
and the other freaks the fight is
eventually broken off and Darren is
saved from certain Doom however when the
dust settles it is revealed that Merlot
has kidnapped Rebecca the following
morning Darren sets off to find her as
he blames himself for the entire
incident in the meantime Mr tiny kidnaps
his family hoping to lure him into a
trap after a while Darren arrives at his
home and finds it empty he then notices
a flyer on the table inviting him to the
circus meanwhile larten also decides to
join in on the fight and so he gathers
his weapons in the next scene Darren
makes his way to the circus where he
finds Rebecca and his family tied and
hung up on the wall he is also perplexed
to see Steve with the vampanese
nevertheless he attacks former best
friend without any hesitation while
larten also arrives and starts tussling
with Merlot as Darren has not consumed
any blood he becomes a very weak and
easily gets bruised as compared to Steve
but right then Rebecca frees herself and
orders Darren to drink her blood so that
he can get his energy back initially he
refuses to comply but when Rebecca
assures him that she will be fine he
sucks her blood elsewhere Larkin ends up
being wounded very badly but despite
this he uses the last of his strength
and stabs Merlot right in his heart
killing him immediately afterwards
Darren starts to fight with Steve again
while Mr tiny watches from a distance
having had enough he decides to
intervene and stop them Mr tiny
resuscitates Merlot using his special
powers by turning him into a dwarf
creature he then asks the two boys to
come with him Amazed by his power Steve
immediately obliges but Darren does not
in the aftermath of The Showdown lartin
hypnotizes Darren's family so that their
recent memory is wiped this way they
won't remember this Supernatural events
that took place right in front of their
eyes the movie ends as Darren returns
back to the camp where all of the freaks
welcome him warmly and make him feel
home
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching